I want things for you me as well I want
you to uh enjoy your time here and uh I
want you someday maybe to have a family
do you think that's possible I I'll have
a well a musical family I maybe a family
of animals of an animals you trust me
with children can you imagine me with
babies I think you'd be a great dad yeah
oh you know what I did as a matter of
fact I know we've mentioned this before
but I gave you once for fun when we were
on tour together I gave you an American
Girl doll and you uh I thought just for
fun I gave you one than you and um I
thought that would be it and this tour
lasted a while and you bought a baby
holder Baby Baby Bjorn no relation to
flua you bought a Baby Bjorn and you
took care of this baby beautifully you
brought the baby everywhere and uh and I
thought he'd be a great dad well I'm I'm
very good with an inanimate um object
with legs and arms that cannot pee PE
poo poo or be fed okay all right but an
actual live being I would come would say
be very careful about it yes would you
be tempted if you had seven children uh
to make them sing you know when they
before they went to bed at night yeah I
would if I had seven children I would be
tempted to say hey I be right back I'm
running some errands
everyone oh oh and then you take off
yeah I think I think the minute they
heard you say that they'd know you're
not coming back he doesn't know how to
run and does not understand the word
errands
yes yeah um con you have offspring
yeah I do do you plan on more five five
to six more of these offsprings well I'm
uh I think uh I think no you're very
viral well I know I am mean I think
that's understood when you just hear the
oh yeah podcast it's a delicious voice
my sexual exploits are legendary uh no I
think uh I have two children and they're
they're beautiful and I love them um and
uh I think you know I'm very happy uh in
my in my marriage so no I think that's
it I think that's it for me you know I
think that's it I think there'll be no
more Conan children what finality okay
no I just say I mean I love these two
kids and that's enough for you yeah so
you don't you're not like Constantine or
Alexander you don't need to well in some
ways I am oh yeah a conqueror a
legendary figure whose name Will
resonate through history uh reverberate
if you will I will do it um but no I
will uh I will I'll be happy to if you
had a child I would adopt it you would
adopted my child yeah if you have a
child and you want to take care of it I
will adopt your child I will commence
with the procreation process okay well
what a man you know how to get a lady
into bed yes yes we will now commence
yes now it
happens yeah play the fal yes um what
are you hitting the clubs much recently
I don't hit any of the clubs at all um I
am doing a knot of nighttime playing of
music by myself and then I also play
Trombone in the mornings to awaken my
neighbors and also the world and that
goes over well with them no okay
wouldn't think it would no it I received
many complaints but a glissando there's
no better way to wake up Conan than with
a glissando very nice did you uh that's
a sliding of the trombone as you play a
toot a toot you play a toot you are a
musical Maestro thank you give us a
toot yeah
yeah um do have you ever uh been in an
OAA band no I have observed OAA bands I
have been in um Sho plattler band before
where I yes I Sho plattler and the Oompa
zpa and then we we will join Sho plater
is when you slap yourself and you slap
other people as well yeah a lot of
slapping yes that was chimpanzee as you
did but there will be other items that
you will slap like buttocks and also
knees and also toes it's like that song
yeah it's it's a crazy uh crazy I got to
do it with Andy RoR once there's a
remote you can see online where Andy RoR
and I a shoe plater it's one of my
favorite remotes we ever did because
it's out of it's insane you were there
for that actually I observed it you
observed it it was absolute Madness it
was the most German people observing you
with absolute germanity yeah very great
they would they refuse to giggle or
laugh at anything you said no no and I
loved it it's one of my look it up it's
online go check that out I saw you be
excited at people not enjoying you oh
that's my favorite thing when people
aren't enjoying me there's a there's a
delight uh I feel
um probably when some people describe
going towards the light when they die
and they feel this peace and this calm
and they know they're going towards
their loved ones that's how I feel when
people when I'm going too far in One
Direction and people around me don't
like it yes I'm in Nirvana I'm as happy
as I can be I feel this as well when I
do things Conan why I don't understand
this but it is a delicious time it's
like oh everything everyone thinks this
is terrible but I'm still enjoying this
snack yes and I love sometimes that oh
um this is we are born alone and we die
alone and this is this moment this pure
moment where I'm on stage in front of
all these people and I'm so delighted
with myself no one's following me on
this and I don't know how to describe it
but I I feel uh effervescent yeah this
is a metaphor for my entire life and I'm
very excited about this Conan do you
find that this is more fun or less fun
than we people are like giggling and
laughing and clapping at you which
feeling is I always hear laughter and
giggling in my head oh it's so right
yeah right now I'm killing right now
Crush Crush Crush Crush Crush Crush yeah
yeah when I order in a restaurant I hear
huge Applause when you hit order on the
Postmates you oh I'm like whoa standing
ovation Chicago Theater 10% tip
uh 8% is as high as I will go that's the
most yeah single digs yeah keep in the
singles I always say course
yeah buy this whole oh CHP a lot why
what's the point of that exactly why do
we do
it you're such a good improv partner yes
he yes why do we do
it um let's play a quick improv game
right now yes and okay let's try it
right now well this is pretty hard work
isn't it Joe oh that's right John I am
also hurting from my back and also hips
oh man I can't believe we have to dig so
many holes oh this this this is so sad
look at this hole it's not deep enough
yeah well time to fill it with
marshmallow because this is marshmallow
University I thought that was a terrific
improv oh was that it well okay we'll
keep going yes yes I sure love it here
at marshmallow University me as well
good thing have enough chocolate
otherwise we would be making some
lessers some what sores lessers less I
didn't know what Les was opposite it's
the opposite some lesses a joke to
compare with smores which you got that
yeah I didn't Adam did you get that did
you get that Eduardo did you get that
play okay 1 2 3 four I declare some War
okay stop it stop it and a pinky piece
yes see yes I won't have it I will not
have it I agree I thought that was is
terrible I agree with you you just blew
up the Improv and of course goly goes
with you on it yes but my inside brain
was also laughing
um I think you and I work very well
together uh we did some improv on stage
and then uh when I would do Q&A with the
audience you would run around with the
microphone and my favorite thing is you
would trip or bump into someone and say
in German Witch
is until you'd be running around the
microphone going and You' be going sh sh
sh I don't know why that just that made
me laugh really hard it was ACC I Wasing
a lot of pinches people are pinching you
know pinch me if this is a real thing
happening so I received lots of pinches
lot of uh would you say people were
coming on to you I don't really know how
to read uh these things like is someone
attracted to me as usually if someone's
giving you a pinch where where on your
body it was usually buttock region and
also between the buttocks well that is
someone uh actually molesting you that's
someone molesting you T tun what the tun
no it's the taint taint not tunt tun is
that's just wrong tun is Tun is that's
just don't ever say tun again tunt is
the weird it just sounds so wrong
because already the taint is the in
between of something so the tun feels
like even more in don't even talk about
it you know what you're not allowed to
talk about itly the tun is inside the
taint you're saying okay don't don't I'm
saying I'm I'm outlawing this word I
love it no more tun I'm good at this yes
okay yeah no more tun okay it's a tun
free zone okay taints only in this in
this this
be you know what my favorite musical is
tell me more tun
misbehaving listen yes do you know what
my favorite Baseball hit is what's that
a tun oh yes of course it was really
yeah the bun yeah it's one they hit the
ball very slowly worst improv ever this
is terrible they don't hit the
whatever